Speaker 1: Let's go back to the discord lines
and hear from a few more people you can join at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go first
to. Oh, I don't know. How about Sean from Miami?
Sean, what's going on?
Speaker 4:
Hello. David Taylor can deodorize unpleasant.
I just want to ask about your thoughts on
the protests going on in Iran now blasted
over a month at this point. And what you think
their effects will be, as in do you expect any
kind of liberal reform or even regime change?
Speaker 1: I feel like I should not comment
about my expectations because I would just
be spitballing. And one of the things I try
to do on the show is if I don't really
have facts on which to base an opinion,
why am I just going to interject my voice? I
don't need to have an opinion on everything.
And so I'm aware of the protests. I know
that the goal is liberal reforms. I simply
cannot add anything productive to the
conversation. So I'm going to let the
experts continue to weigh in on that.
Speaker 4: I totally understand. We're
generally not that good at predicting, so.
Speaker 1: We're generally even let let's. That's
another good point. Even if I did know more about
it, we're terrible at making predictions, but I'm
glad to make predictions about things I know a
little bit more about. Like, for example, I've
been following the polling for the midterms very
closely for a year and a half, so I'm glad to make
predictions there. But anyway, you get the point.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah. Well,
thanks for your time, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to hear
from our friends in Miami, as always. Reminder
to everybody on the discord waiting to get on.
You need to have if you want the opportunity to
get on your name and where you're calling from,
it doesn't have to be real. I don't know where
you're really calling from or what your name is,
but it can't be nicknames, it can't be
usernames, it can't be obvious like name
parodies and things like that. Okay.
Just a reminder for people who may be
wondering why they're not getting called
on. Let's go to David from Oakland. David,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind?
Speaker 6: Thanks for taking my call.
My pleasure. So I just kind of want to get
your opinion on the Fed policy going forward
and trying to tamp down inflation. And I think
what is it that the Fed wants to inflict pain
and that how unemployment, they want to put some
people out of work to cool down inflation. Yeah,
we've seen what Jerome Powell has said and
what senators like Elizabeth Warren feel
about it. So I want to get your opinion on that.
Speaker 1: I am concerned that inflation is going
to come down, but it's going to come down in
due time and slightly more slowly than the Fed
would like to see it come down. And that as a
result, the Fed is going to overplay its hand
with the raising of rates and is going to create
too much of an economic slowdown. When partially
what we need to do is just wait, because some
of this inflation is the result of supply chain
issues. Some of the inflation is a result
of energy prices which have started to come
down. And so my concern, you know, of course, I
don't pretend to have all of the information or
to study this as closely as the people at the
Fed do. But big picture, a general concern with
with a Fed that becomes committed to raising rates
and raising them for a significant period of time
is there is more of a delay before the effect
is felt on prices because the inflation has to
do with some seasonal or not seasonal, temporary
and transient things that are starting to resolve,
and that before you know it, the
Fed will have gone too far and will
damage the economy. That's my concern.
Speaker 6: That's kind of my concern,
too. And it's also just such a backwards
concept. It seems that they want people
out of work to cool things down.
Speaker 1: And you get the economics
of it right. It sounds like you do, right?
Yeah. The idea being fewer people employed,
fewer people who can afford stuff reduces
demand and then prices come down. Yeah, exactly.
Speaker 6: It's a weird concept. And, you know,
the market outlook for 2023, I know markets are
forward leaning, but it just, you know, net
negative hiring, layoffs. It just it's like
everybody's predicting catastrophe and, you
know, is it going to be like, great, my savings
account yields 4%, but I can't find a job. Right.
Speaker 1: No, I know. I mean, listen, obviously,
employment and being able to meet your monthly
expenses is the top priority for everyone. And
absent that, people are in real trouble. For
those who will remain employed and able to afford
their day to day expenses, my advice is advice
that I would give no matter what's going on.
Figure out your asset allocation, how much you're
saving in cash, how much you're putting into
stocks and bonds, ideally through super low cost
index funds. And if things continue declining over
the next year, you will have picked up more and
more shares at lower and lower prices, which will
eventually yield more return when things recover.
And if things do well in the next year, then the
shares that you already own will be worth more
at the end of that year. Either way, as long as
your outlook is more than a few years out, you're
going to better position yourself for 5 to 7 years
from now. And that's the funny thing is that's
always my advice, no matter what's going on.
Speaker 6: Well, that's why we watch
the Pacman Finance Channel. Exactly
right. So thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. My pleasure.
And you you are you super chat often
during the live streams, right?
Speaker 4: Yeah. Big photo.
Speaker 1: I very much appreciate
that. Thanks for the support.
Speaker 4: Of course.
Speaker 1: All right. There we go. David from
Oakland with a very important economic question,
super powerful declaration,
and I really appreciate that.